hey YouTube what you're about to watch
is a new segment we call change my mind
pretty simple we go out and set up in
public and pick a topic in this video
it's second Amendment where I just say
hey listen I'm pro-gun change my mind
and we actually allow people from other
points of view to come up and
proactively change my mind I'd love to
hear from you what what topics you would
like to hear discuss on this also it's
important this isn't about just a debate
or a highlight reel the point to this
exercise is to actually get people to
question their own point of view and see
if their argument is rational and maybe
at the end of it they'll end up changing
their own mind so pro-gun Second
Amendment change my mind
enjoy very pro-gun pro-second amendment
changed my mind I'm open
do you believe guns have uses other than
hunting yes what do you believe those
are I believe that the Second Amendment
the Second Amendment I should clarify is
about the basic right to
self-preservation be that from internal
threats be they're from domestic threats
would be definitely threat of a
tyrannical government that's the purpose
and intent of a second matter that is my
contention I agree with the Second
Amendment has that intention however I
do think that guns aren't necessarily
the most effective way of defense
I believe that guns are so easy to show
would you mind putting the mic just to
you just do it yeah sorry so I believe
that if you have a gun if for example in
the case of a home invasion sure if you
are a good a gun owner have it in a safe
in a safe place and you know not like
under your pillow or anything and you
take care of it then by the time you get
to your gun
it probably is already too late to
defend yourself sure well I guess that's
defined true
maybe we're not disagreeing it seems
like maybe your pro Second Amendment you
believe that people have the right to
purchase in their arms as to whether an
individual is effective in defending
their house with their own firearm I can
tell you that mine is very easily
accessible and many of them are and that
wouldn't be the scenario so it doesn't
change the right for me to have that
firearm to protect my home I also
believe that there is definitely a
reason to have them for sport not not
just hunting but also aiming practice
gun ranges I have a friend who was on
their way to actually becoming a
professional marksman but then they got
glaucoma yeah but that's not what the
Second Amendment is about so I guess
we're still we've really yeah come out
looking to change my mind on that you
agree people have the right to purchase
and bear arms yes I have a disagreement
with the mostly the concealed carry laws
and such in that I believe that you know
having a gun for you know the purposes
I've set out is perfectly fine but
that's no reason to carry one around in
public particularly because it could be
used against you someone could grab it
off your person and threaten you with it
someone could take your car and run you
over with it yes but I mean that we
can't sell you a car cars actually kill
way more people than guns but cars are
necessary to get to point eight
from from point A to point me third you
can take public transportation you can
take a bike you can walk not everywhere
not everyone has public fears always
what many literally areas you need you
need a car in order to get several miles
to the grocery store to get your food
food let me ask you is it your
contention that because something you
can legally own could be used against
you or someone else the government has
the right to tell you that you couldn't
own said item is that your
presupposition
I believe that it's not like you can't
own it you can own it it's that you
can't for no good reason bring it out in
public what would be no good reason what
would be a good reason for someone to
have to be able to exercise their right
to protect themselves a good reason is I
am bringing this gun to the gun range to
go not to protect myself let's get rid
of the sports in the hunting aspect of
it right the second one is just to
protect yourself so why is it again I'm
hearing why does the government have the
right if I'm a law-abiding citizen to
tell me that I cannot protect myself
with my firearm because the whole point
of having a government is to trust the
government to protect you no - no that's
not true
because as a woman I feel very
threatened walking around at night on my
own you should probably get a gun I have
an app on my phone where I can set it up
where one touch brings the police to my
location and it actually alerts the
police that I might have a call when I
click a certain button like if I'm
feeling somewhat threatened I click one
let me ask a question you're open that
last question the police come what what
would the police be able to do that you
wouldn't
they are able to physically if not
intimidate than let's say a very violent
attacker okay you call the police you
are calling the police because because I
fear for my life and they would protect
you yes with with firearms because they
are trained and they have they have a
legal responsibility to use those
firearms properly in a way that casual
firearms owners do not final question do
you believe we have a police brutality
problem yes I do I believe that police
need to be trained better than they are
now but do you believe in a society
where police exclusively are granted the
rights to carry firearms no police not
only police I say I say police should
have firearms to deal with violent
individuals let threaten with the police
officers life okay whereas the everyday
person should be able to rely on the
police to do that now the problem we
have is that we aren't able to rely on
that I don't think the problem I don't
think the solution to that is get guns I
think the solution to that is reform the
police department I disagree with you do
you think that maybe after this
conversation hearing some of the things
that you said talking about how you
believe it's the government it's the job
to trust the government and then I've
talked about inherent corruption in the
government police force I would
encourage you and hope that maybe you
would reconsider some of these stances
moving forward about having a society
where only the police have the right to
carry firearms I think maybe would find
some common ground think about it and
then maybe if I'm still here come back
we can talk about if I know we got some
of the people here in line okay
Danny Danny thank you so much day I
appreciate you taking the time and one
last little clip I'm also particularly
vulnerable to police as a
disabled trans person so I do really
understand the police brutality issue
right but I think that guns aren't the
answer so thank you all right Sam Steven
nice to meet you Sam would you mind
holding the microphone up when you talk
to Suakin huh yeah you know how those
works talking to the talking linetti
thing yeah Sam so you said you're a
program but you believe in some control
yeah okay you're in college you're
obviously a smart guy I think it's
important than to define what it is
we're discussing right yeah when you say
some controls what kind of control
controls that actually you know a lot of
Americans when they're trying to get a
license for guns or they're trying to
purchase guns or whatever they should be
able they should be able to document it
and not with paper but with machine
documentation so and on top of that they
should go through a psych evaluation if
they're too violent or they have a
faster being too violent then they
should be restricted or completely opted
out of even owning a gun depending on
how violent they are we go so you're
saying that if somebody has a documented
history of violence mm-hmm they should
not be able to purchase a firearm yes or
they should be restricted to only
probably a handgun okay well that's
interesting I'd like to go back to that
mic a little closer to so I could okay
everyone's getting lucky so if I were to
tell you it's already the law I assume
you've never first to know it's already
the law you can't buy a firearm if
you're violent and they said but maybe
only restrict it to a handgun that's I
find that curious why would someone be
restricted to a handgun above other guns
because here's the thing again every
American has a right to own a firearm
and that's the Second Amendment we
cannot change that we cannot take that
away from them and that's something we
should always protect I appreciate that
but
demoting them down to was say a handgun
that doesn't take away the fact that hey
maybe someone might come into their
house and you know might steal something
or my effect their family or whatever
and just because they're a criminal
doesn't always mean they're just like
always going to be violent all and all
that stuff if they have a handgun to at
least protect themselves and not cause
mass damage - like what happened in Las
Vegas right then that way they're
protecting themselves and they won't be
out there to harm others and if they do
we also have the police at hand to at
least you know limit casualties and
always forgive me if it seems like I'm
interrupting guys cuz you go - that's
work I want to kind of address each
point so we can find out whether we
again so my understanding is that you're
saying we should limit these people to
handguns yes as opposed to long rifles
semi-automatic rifles and this with
which they could commit mass damage so
in order to mitigate the damage yes
what if I were to tell you that
unequivocally it's not even close the
vast majority of mass shootings take
place with handguns
well again people put modifications on
the guns and I understand that a lot of
mass shootings also happen with handguns
know most the home almost nearly all
says yeah but I also think that actually
let me refer let me step back a bit and
where I'm pulling this idea of handguns
is there was a article I read about
someone cleaning I hang on that only
registered to yours like biometrics have
you heard of it yes I have yes sure but
yes continue it is a disaster but the
reason I'm touching on that is because
it's a really good idea and the NRA
which I kind of have a problem with
right now is not laying us research guns
in a sense or making them completely
safe as from what I understand I'm not
to educate on what the NRA is doing
right now is just how they conduct more
research on guns than anyone in the
country
yeah and they always find a way to like
make sure there's no gun controls going
on and all that stuff but um let me say
people are able to able if own
modifications are on their guns which of
course should be completely unalaq bumps
dogs there's also there's also this a
bump stock is basically if you fire a
gun that thing just bounces back there's
also a needle in which you can put in
your guns where if you pull the trigger
it constantly forces your finger back so
it's kind of like an automatic rifle
right and that's of course should be
illegal as well and going back to why
I'm saying demote people to handguns yes
they're almost all machines are camila
handguns again I'm saying people should
go through background checks and all
that stuff that already have that
already exists but it's not too refined
I mean here's one thing I would say
respectfully and I would just I do
disagree with you on several instance
but I appreciate taking the time I think
that there's a discussion taking place
in this country yeah and it's between
two camps you're not gonna like what I'm
about to say but it's not meant as a
personal insult no no it's between gun
owners mm-hmm and completely
ill-informed if you've purchased a
firearm you would know that everything
you've just said is untrue yeah and I
don't set to insult you know you in fact
I would recommend you go purchase a
firearm for yourself even if you're
getting off just getting a gun revolver
okay I mean a 22 revolver okay you'll go
through a background check you'll see
asking the questions you're going to ask
for your license you're going to make
sure it's the same address that you
currently live
it'll probably be the most stringent
background check you've ever gone
through it was more stringent than
Social Security okay so all those things
already exist a bump stock is not we
described it to be as a matter of fact I
can make a bump stop with my belt really
really about you it's a technique a bump
stock allows you to optimize a certain
technique okay and it's already illegal
to modify a gun to a fully automatic
rifle okay this is already illegal right
so someone taking a firearm and
modifying it to make it in a illegal
firearm okay is already against the law
it's already against the law to purchase
a firearm it's
you are a convicted felon if you're a
violent criminal you mentioned the NRA
there's so much research conducted on
firearms as a matter of fact if I were
to ask you how many defensive uses do
you think there are firearms each year
if you were to guess you knows about
theirs I would say a good couple hundred
thousand maybe into millions yeah into
Millions
how many gun deaths do you think you are
I would say around ten to twenty
thousand per year a little higher than
that but lower than that if you remove
suicides okay so again there's these are
important and a lot of these come from
from pro firearm associations I think
what is important to have this
discussion and I hope it's been
illuminating maybe thanks mayor plants
me I would really encourage you to buy a
fire yeah even if you go right back and
just trade it in you can buy it and then
give it right back to the gun shop and
they'll consign it where they run a
background so if you don't want to spend
the money yeah that's a very experience
where you learn the things that you
thought were not sure and I think it
starts from the the preset position and
I think we certain the common ground the
Second Amendment is not about hunting
humans about the basic right to
self-preservation and we either support
the idea that we have the right to
protect ourselves both our houses our
families our property from local threats
or tyrannical threat from the government
we either agree on that and I think we
do or we don't now and if you've read it
to write like three speeches are right
yeah the government cannot remove a
basic human right unless you've
forgotten it by violating someone else's
rises yeah and I mean that's I love I
love the second I mean I love the
Constitution and I love America how it
is and I just love the idea that if some
other country tries to invade us we have
the firearm not only do we have the
police and a great military but we also
have the American people who are
definitely going to be pissed off shoot
the other guy one thing I want to ask
and you were telling me to go ahead and
purchase a firearm now I don't mean to
sound offensive to anyone or any of you
or the thing is I'm a person of color
and I'm not even a black person I'm just
a brown person yeah and the derogatory
the Serio type I'm always
is I'm basically a terrorist just by my
skin color right no one knows my
background and all that stuff and I've
come from a very conservative location
back in Florida now if I purchase a
firearm and if I am team around with the
gun I know for a fact people are always
going to view me as a threat
well there's that one saying carrier you
don't need to carry it around out in the
open yeah you legally can now in Texas
but concealed okay okay that spread on
down the trip isn't it wonderful that
there are horrible racist ass because
the color of your skin and think that
you're a terrorist
yeah isn't it wonderful that that
doesn't affect your rights yeah that's
completely amazing
yeah it doesn't affect it because guess
what that background check if you
haven't committed a crime you have the
same rights as that racist [ __ ] down
the street yeah definitely and that's
the only thing is you know we either
have to agree on the freedom of the
right for all of us to protect ourselves
and we don't and I can't imagine what
it's like as I'm sure you've dealt with
with you know racist encounters your
whole life and it's always sad to hear
but um again that doesn't think take
policy and I would look at that and say
hey isn't it great that despite what one
individual things it doesn't affect your
rights as an American citizen like and
that's the beauty of blind justice and
if you give that authority to the
government or if you give that authority
to an individual or a committee yeah
guess what it just takes one of those
racist people to make a decision for you
or vice versa so it's it's pretty
important right especially for
minorities to make to ensure that that
they're not in their rights aren't
infringed upon by the mob of the
majority right I don't think that anyone
should be able to vote the brown people
can't have guns any more than I think no
one's be able to vote that anyone here
can't have guns yeah but it's also let's
say I'm gonna defend myself at home with
the gun I perjured all that stuff and I
happen to shoot the intruder I don't
know if he's a threat or not now here
comes the main problem as to why I
personally won't buy a gun though I love
guns I won't buy a gun if that gets out
into the media I'm a brown person with a
gun that killed
and in tutor yeah now in that scenario
already I'm always gonna I'm already
gonna be classified as someone who's
again very violent in all this stuff but
are you studying me I'm a computer
engineer good engineer yeah I would
encourage you we do I know there are
other people are so we had to go see me
but encourage you to read up more in a
Socratic method yes I think that if you
question some of the things and I think
we've done it here where you
reestablished I mean your your views a
little bit I think if you question some
of the premises of your your positions
here you'll realize they're not
necessarily true yeah and not
necessarily some that you can certainly
confirm is true yeah and I do think
especially in today's era more important
than political correctness more
important than sensitivity more
important than opinion it is more
important than even common ground is
truth yes I think if you examine some of
your premises I say this respectfully I
think you'll find that they are
incorrect
yeah and that's what I really hope from
coming into here because I'm saying I
want I want gun control right right and
just sitting down and hearing about this
of course I listen to TYT and I listen
to very progressive news outlets I'm not
I'm not an innocent in any ways with
this biased media who do you listen to
on the right on the right
I want to write like uit on the far far
left right so yes who do you listen to
to balance that out I to be honest
nothing else
I honestly mostly I listen to CNN
anything on TYT is just me events that
happen around the world I never really
take their side because again I don't
like socialism that much I think there
has to be a balance so do you think
watching TYT and CNN do you feel maybe
as though they've almost starting to a
startling degree have under-equipped you
yes definitely no one this because and
maybe it's by design like the fact that
that some that you may not know that
there already are background checks yeah
their news that's their job to let you
know yeah and that's definitely a case
and again I'm also not comfortable with
watching Fox News because I know there's
some stuff that are not true over there
and I've already found that out sure but
again going to CNN of course I also know
some stuff are not true I didn't know it
would lie to this extent
again TYT great people there I really
think they just need a bump up the
information more and it's just bump up
the information yeah and maybe you could
start watching some more right-leaning
channels yeah definitely but it's just
kind of heartbreaking that I'm look I'm
looking at only like love channels I'm
still not getting enough information or
I'm not getting all the information I
need right yeah and thank you for this
experience in telling me all this stuff
Thank You Sammy I appreciate it brother
god bless in your studies and hearing
that's no joke it's not that no I'm not
a student here I do have ID with me is
there a reason if you even look at my
identification
there you are YouTube I remain
unconvinced though I did enjoy meeting
the Oracle from the Minority Report
I do think hopefully this is a
productive thing to do a lot of people
talk about wanting to engage in
discussion and they don't do it you
don't have to agree you don't have to
find common ground you just have to be
rational and I would love to hear what
other topics you'd like discussed and
subscribe by hitting the subscribe
button or one of these other videos I
think playing inboxes I'm not entirely
sure because YouTube changes everything
this might not even exist anymore
because it's been struck down oh well
what do you do
YouTube overlords they're gonna do
YouTube Overlord gonna youtube overlord